Hey David, auch meine Freunde sind offensichtlich
deine größten Fans, du glaubst das jetzt vielleicht nicht,
weil wir alle 16 Jahre alt sind
, das stimmt, also habe ich auch eine Frage an
dich, weil ich gelesen habe, dass du
ein Stück Land und den Norden Deutschlands kaufen möchtest
in einer Stadt namens Hasselhoff, weil du
denkst, du könntest einige deiner
Verwandten finden, dort ist diese Geschichte wahr, denn
für mich klingt es ein bisschen seltsam, nun, ich würde
mich so freuen, wenn du meine Frage beantwortest,
und ich liebe dich so sehr, David, glaub mir
und ja  Das war meine Frage, meine
Antwort lautet: Ich habe eine Stadt namens
Hasselhoff Deutschland gefunden und ich wollte dorthin gehen
und ein Stück Land kaufen, damit ich
dorthin ziehen könnte, weil ich wirklich wollte, dass meine
Adresse David Hasselhoff Deutschland ist,
es ist eine sehr kleine Adresse und sehr  einfach
aber ich habe jetzt herausgefunden das es
keine hasselhoff gibt bald hasselhoff dass sie
in focusin wohnen focusin ist in der nähe von bremen
und da kam mein ur-ur-
urgroßvater eigentlich her und ich
habe ein foto und da bin ich in
die gefahren  hasselhoff hassle Hoff Hasselhoff
stammt aus Haselnuss, wo sie eine
Haselnussfarm hatten und ein Haselnussbaum
geht bis ins 15. Jahrhundert zurück, und ich habe ein Ticket
meines Ururgroßvaters Karl
Hasselhoff, der von Bremen
bis nach Baltimore, Maryland, kam, wo er einen
Sohn namens hatte  Joseph Hasselhoff, der einen
Sohn namens Joseph Hasselhoff hatte, der mein
Vater ist, und so haben wir herausgefunden, dass meine
Wurzeln tatsächlich aus Fulkerson stammen. Ich
weiß nicht einmal, ob ich es sagen kann, aber meine
Verwandten sind dort und ich plane,
dorthin zurückzukehren  Ich konzentriere mich und verbringe etwas
Zeit mit meinen Verwandten, weil dort
Hasselhoffs sind, und danke, dass Sie
in meiner Ecke sind. Ich liebe es, junge
Fans zu haben, besonders so süß wie Sie